I should mention this is a brief tangent
back to the place where we came from
which is the base model that I mentioned
for open AI which is before the
reinforcement learning with human
feedback and you kind of give this
metaphor of it being kind of like a
psychiatric hospital I like that because
it's basically all of these different
angles at once like you basically have
the more extreme versions of human
psyche so the interesting thing is
well I've talked with folks in openai
quite a lot and they say it's extremely
difficult to work with that model yeah
kind of like it's extremely difficult to
work with some humans the parallels
there are very interesting because once
you run the alignment process it's much
easier to interact with it but it makes
you wonder what the capacity with the
underlying capability of the human
psychias as in the same way that what is
the underlying capability of a large
language model and remember earlier when
I was basically saying that
um part of the reason why it's so prompt
malleable is because of that alignment
problem that alignment work it's kind of
nice that the engineers at open AI have
the same interpretation that you know in
fact it is that and um this whole
concept of easier to work with
um
I I wish that we could work with more
diverse humans
in a way
and and sort of that's one of the
possibilities that I see with the Advent
of these large language models
the fact that
it gives us the chance to both dial down
friends of ours that we can't interpret
or that are just too edgy to sort of
really truly interact with where you
could have a real-time translator
just the same way that you can translate
English to Japanese or Chinese or Korean
by like real-time adaptation you could
basically suddenly have a conversation
with your favorite extremist on either
side of the spectrum and just dial them
down a little bit
of course not you and I but uh you could
uh have friends that are who's a
complete [__] uh but it's a different
base level so you can actually tune it
down to like okay they're not actually
being an [__] there this is uh
they're actually expressing love right
now it's just that this is a they have
their way of of doing that and they
probably live in New York uh if we're
just to pick a random location so so
that yeah so you can basically layer out
contexts you can basically say oh let me
change New York to Texas and let me
change you know uh extreme left extreme
right or somewhere in the middle or
something and
um I also like the concept of being able
to
um
listen to the information without being
dissuaded by the emotions in other words
everything humans say has an intonation
has some kind of background that they're
coming from it reflects the way that
they're thinking of you reflects the
impression that they have of you and all
of these things are intertwined
but being able to disconnect them being
able to sort of
I mean self-improvement is one of the
things that I'm constantly working on
and being able to receive criticism
from people who really hate you is
difficult because it's layered in with
that hatred but deep down there's
something that they say that actually
makes sense or people who love you might
layer it in a way that doesn't come
through but if you're able to sort of
Disconnect that emotional component from
the sort of self-improvement
and basically when somebody says whoa
that was a bunch of [__] did you
ever do the control this and this and
that you could just say
oh thanks for the very interesting
presentation uh you know I'm wondering
what about that control then suddenly
you're like oh yeah of course I'm going
to run that control that's a great idea
instead of that was a bunch of BS you're
like ah you're sort of hitting on the
brakes and you're trying to push back
against of that so
any kind of criticism that comes after
that it's very difficult to interpret in
a positive way because it helps
reinforce the negative assessment of
your work when in fact if we
disconnected the technical component
from the negative assessment then
you're embracing the negative then
you're embracing the technical component
you're going to fix it whereas if it's
coupled with and if that thing is real
and I'm right about your mistake then
it's a it's a bunch of BS then suddenly
you're like you're gonna try to prove
that that mistake does not exist
he has fascinating to like carry the
information I mean this is what you're
essentially able to do here is you carry
the information in the rich complexity
that information contains so it's not
actually dumbing it down in some way
Zach is still expressing it but taking
off but you can die the the the the
emotional the emotion side yeah which is
probably so powerful for the internet or
for social networks again when it comes
to understanding each other one like for
example I don't know what it's like to
go through life with a different skin
color
I don't know how people will perceive me
I don't know how people will respond to
me
we don't often have that experience
but in a virtual reality environment or
in a sort of AI interactive system you
could basically say okay now make me
Chinese or make me South African or make
me you know uh Nigerian
you can change the accent you can change
layers of
that contextual information and then see
how the information is interpreted and
you can re-hear yourself through a
different angle you can hear others you
can have others react to you from a
different package
and then hopefully we can sort of build
empathy by learning to disconnect all of
these social cues that we get from like
how a person is dressed you know if
they're wearing a hoodie or if they're
wearing a shirt or if they're wearing a
you know jacket you get very different
emotional responses that you know I wish
we could overcome as humans and perhaps
large language models and augmented
reality and deep fakes can kind of help
us overcome all that